-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
how is everybody doing tonight
Alright! Good to hear.
Even on a Monday? Okay.
Let's get to the news.
Following the news
that Kentucky Derby winner
Medina Spirit had failed
a post-race drug test,
former President Trump
released a statement
on his website yesterday,
that said,
"So, now, even our
Kentucky Derby winner,
Medina Spirit is a junkie,
which brings us to a segment
called "Dammit,
That's Really Funny."
[ Theme music plays ]
Okay, obviously,
I dislike this man.
But it is possible
to dislike someone
and think calling a horse
a junkie is very, very funny
This was an official statement
from the former president,
calling a horse a junkie.
As if it bought the drugs itself
in some back alley.
Like it only got caught
'cause the horse's parents
found it in a shoebox
under its bed, its stable?
Again, I cannot stress enough,
I do not like this man.
But, dammit, it's really funny
This has been "Damn It,
That's Really Funny."
Maryland Governor Larry Hoga
criticized
his fellow Republicans
in an interview yesterday
for continuing to support
former President Trump,
and said, "It just bothers m
that you have to swear fealt
to the dear leader, or you get
kicked out of the party."
If only there was a way
that we could have
seen all of this coming.
Republican Congressman Ada
Kinzinger
yesterday criticized the GOP
for the ongoing debate
whether to remove
Conference Chair Liz Cheney,
and said the party is
"basically the Titanic."
I don't know, though.
When the "Titanic" went down
people tried to get off it
"Women and children first,
and then we party,
right, gentlemen?"
Florida Governor Ron DeSanti
signed new voting restrictions
into law last week
at the airport Hilton
in West Palm Beach,
and only allowed Fox News
to broadcast the event.
Also, the airport Hilton
in West Palm Beach
is now Florida's
only polling place.
According to reports, Microsof
co-founder Bill Gates' wife,
Melinda, may have filed
for divorce
over concerns about her
husband's previous dealing
with sex trafficker Jeffre
Epstein.
Wow, even Bill Gates has trouble
clearing his history.
According to Politico,
87-year-old Iowa Senator
Chuck Grassley
gets up at 4:00 a.m. every day
as well as 5:15, 6:00 a.m.
6:45, and 7:10.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, 87-year-old
Iowa Senator Chuck Grassle
gets up at 4:00 a.m. every day
and often goes for
a two-mile run
and does push-Ups.
Said Grassley, "I do?"
[ Laughter ]
The manager of a movie theater
in Minnesota
was recently arrested
for allegedly selling cocain
alongside popcorn, and
was pretty brazen about it
[ Laughter ]
A small sketch of a bear
by Leonardo da Vinci,
measuring less than
8 square inches
is expected to sell
at an auction
for over $16 million,
which is way too high
because da Vinci was originall
trying to draw a dog.
"It's no good.
"No, it's very good."
[ Laughter ]
"It's a bear?"
"It's a dog!"
[ Laughter ]
Finally, yesterday was singe
Billy Joel's 72nd birthday
And this time, he did
almost start the fire.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, wait."
And that was the monologue